let's get back sie dann
[Applaus]
alle haben davor gewarnt dass dies der
anfang vom ende sei dass der exit früher
oder später den zusammen druck der
mächtigen londoner finanzindustrie
herbeiführen würde
[Musik]
sie sagten voraus dass es frankfurt
paris oder sogar amsterdam gelingen
würde die macht des city zu brechen
zusammen mit new york bittet sie
immerhin eines der beiden wichtigsten
finanzzentren der welt um die eine
vorstellung davon zu geben im
vereinigten königreich werden etwa 2,5
mal mehr dollar gehandelt als er den
vereinigten staaten selbst und warum das
so ist wirst du in diesem video erfahren
nun ist der praxis aber bereits eine
ganze weile realität und das hat uns
hier bei visual politik zusammen mit
unseren freunden von der wendel scu dazu
veranlasst ein paar fragen zu stellen
warum wird zusammen mit new york als die
große finanzloch stadt der welt
bezeichnet welchen einfluss hat die city
of london wirklich auf die globale
finanzwelt ist ihre globale stellung so
bedroht wie ihre kritiker behaupten und
die ist die bilanz des drecks it hat er
sich für die city gelohnt oder hat er
hier eher geschadet nun all diese fragen
werden wir heute beantworten und zwar
gleich nach einer kurzen werbeanlage
unseres treuen sponsoren ibm der auch
dieses video möglich gemacht hat ja ich
mache gerne werbung für surfer gibt die
an wenn ich nutze diesen dienst selbst
und kann ihn ohne bedenken
weiterempfehlen aber wozu braucht man
eigentlich einen virtual private network
vpn nun da wären gleich mehrere vorteile
zum einen eher schwer des allen
möglichen leuten von angreifern bis zu
der betreibenden eure aktionen im
letzten nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören es
bietet unzählige sicherheits features
mit denen ihr eure anonymität im netz
erhöht zum beispiel greenback dass alle
cookies popups und auch fortgeschrittene
identifizierungs und nachverfolgung
mechanismen sicher bloggt und die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt ein
weiterer vorteil eines problem ist dass
ihr so tun können als die in einem
anderen ort so könnt ihr zum beispiel
auf websites und internet dienste
zugreifen die in dem land in dem wir
gerade seitens verfügbar wären ob daheim
oder im urlaub damals lag der zensur und
die geo blocking ein schnippchen netflix
und anderes training diese dir inhalte
nur in den usa anbieten wollen europa
ausnutzen oder deutsches internet
fernsehen im ausland gucken mit soft
kein problem aber das ist noch lange
nicht alles denn mit so einer kommt ja
wirklich alle endgeräte im vpn
registrieren handys notebooks und sogar
eure nach tv so und wenn ihr den
rabattcode politik.de angibt bekommt ihr
von surf schlag auch noch einen rabatt
in höhe von 83 prozent und obendrein die
ersten drei monate gratis dazu den link
zu diesem angebot findet ihr die
beschreibung unter diesen video also
nichts wie los besorgt ausläuft hatten
greift damit gleichzeitig auch uns
finanziell unter die arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe des
paypal spenden links den ich ebenfalls
in die beschreibungen gepackt haben wir
sind euch für jede unterstützung dankbar
denn damit hätten wir uns auch in
zukunft noch mehr und noch besseren
videos zu liefern so und nun ab über den
kanal wir reisen direkt in die city of
landen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
genau genommen ist die city aufladen
auch bekannt als die cd oder wer mal
eine der 33 stadtbezirke aus dem greater
london besteht allerdings ist dieser
bezirk ganz anders als alle übrigen
[Musik]
und wie zum beispiel eine eigene
regierung und sie mehr autonomie als die
anderen bezirke die den großraum london
will die städtische körperschaft der
city kann auf sage und schreibe 2000
jahre selbstverwaltung zurückbringen sie
ist die älteste noch existierende
demokratische formation der welt
natürlich handelt es sich um eine etwas
ungewöhnliche demokratie denn in der
city stimmen nicht nur die einwohner ab
sondern auch die unternehmen durch ihre
angestellten aufgrund dieser regelung
haben die unternehmen sogar mehr stimmen
als die einwohner selbst
[Musik]
wenn diese wie für eine sache bekannt
ist beim dafür dass sie sich auf die
finanzindustrie spezialisiert hat und
damit eine der beiden wichtigsten
finanzzentren der welt seinen namen gab
in der sz in canary wharf haben sie es
geschafft dass fast 800.000 menschen in
hochqualifizierten jobs finanz branche
arbeiten landesweite das gas 2,3
millionen sie ist das was viele als das
letzte überbleibsel des britischen
empire bezeichnen aber die wichtig ist
die rolle londons ende internationalen
szene wirklich und welche rolle genau
spielt ist im globalen maßstab nur um
diese fragen zu beantworten ist es wohl
am besten ein paar fakten auf den tisch
zu legen
[Musik]
dank der cd bringen wenn das
dienstleistungen dem vereinigten
königreich jedes jahr ein
handelsüberschuss von mehr als 80
milliarden dollar ein mehr als 100
milliarden wende die damit verbundenen
dienstleistungen wie anwaltskanzleien
oder beratungsunternehmen mit
einbeziehen
weder singapur noch die schweiz noch die
usa kommen auch nur annähernd an diese
zahl heran ihr glaubt mir nicht nur die
folgenden zahlen sprechen eine
eindeutige sprache
wenn du eine regierung oder ein großes
unternehmen wird und einen großen kredit
zu guten bedingungen aufnehmen willst
hast du in vielen fällen gar keine
andere realistische chance als dies über
london zu tun fast ein fünftel aller
internationalen bankkredite und über
zwölf prozent aller börsennotierten
internationalen anleihen stammen aus dem
vereinigten königreich noch
bemerkenswerter ist dass hier mehr als
40 prozent des weltweiten devisenhandels
abgewickelt werden jeden tag werden mehr
als 2,4 billionen dollar gehandelt
anders ausgedrückt im vereinigten
königreich werden zweieinhalb mal mehr
dollars gehandelt als in den usa selbst
während london auch der größte yuan
handelsblatt außerhalb chinas ist und
das ist noch nicht alles mit mehr als
200 etablierten banken ist die londoner
finanzindustrie eine der größten der
welt in den bereichen private banking
fondsmanagement versicherungen und
finanzderivate diese derivate haben
london und zum beispiel auch zu einem
der wichtigsten handelsplätze für
rohstoffe und energie gemacht
[Musik]
dabei handelt es sich um ganz kontrakte
in denen ein bestimmtes geschäft über
einen basiswert zum beispiel der kauf
oder verkauf eines rohstoffs in der
zukunft vereinbart wird man kann damit
auf eine bestimmte preisentwicklung
wetten oder sich gegen deren
schwankungen absichern ein solches
absicherungsgeschäft wird im englischen
auch hedge genannt man sollte sein
risiko also bildlich gesprochen mit
einer hecke ein davon abgeleitet ist der
begriff des hedgefonds dieser übernimmt
quasi die risiken seiner kunden gegen
entsprechend hohe risikoprämien diese
kunden sind allerdings nicht mit den
anlegern also anteilseigener des
hedgefonds zu verwechseln denn diese
gehen damit dir ein entsprechend höheres
risiko ein was die anzahl der hedgefonds
angeht ist london der zweitgrößter
handelsplatz der welt gleich hinter new
york und wenn es um risikokapital geht
wird die britische hauptstadt
internationalen nur von san francisco
den big apple und boston übertroffen all
das liebe vieh soll konsequenz erklärt
warum diese branche im vereinigten
königreich jedes jahr ein nettoeinkommen
von mehr als 100 milliarden dollar
erwirtschaftet aber an dieser stelle
fragen sich vielleicht viele von euch
warum gerade die city warum ist gerade
sie und london mit er zu einem der
wichtigsten finanzzentren geworden nun
die wahrheit ist dass diese geschichte
sehr weit zurückreicht
während der zeit des britischen empire
wurde london so etwas wie der
knotenpunkt des welthandels ein status
der die entwicklung einer riesigen
finanzindustrie begünstigte so
entstanden unter der themse zb in der
zweiten jahreshälfte des 18 jahrhunderts
die ersten infos der welt und trotz des
niedergangs des empire behielt dc die
ihre bedeutung dies lässt sich durch
drei große historische schiebe erklären
das erste dieser ereignisse fand in den
späten 1950 er jahren statt zu dieser
zeit begann die dollarbestände der
europäischen banken über zu quellen der
grund die usa konsumierten wie verrückt
und verschlangen einen großen teil der
weltproduktion an waren und als
gegenleistung dafür dass die welt sie
mit waren beliefert lieferten die amis
der welt was genau grünen scheinchen
dieser überfluss ein papier mit porträts
amerikanischer präsidenten und die
tatsache dass die britischen
aufsichtsbehörden beschlossen sich nicht
in dollar transaktionen zwischen
ausländischen akteuren einzumischen
führten zur entstehung des euro/dollar
marktes in london dieser riesige markt
für finanzierungen und diesen handel mit
dollars der außerhalb der usa
stattfinden daher nicht der aufsicht der
amerikanischen federal reserve oder
neben bargeld anforderungen unterliegt
es entstand ein riesiger markt für
finanzierungen und in diesen handel mit
dollars der außerhalb der usa
stattfindet und daher nicht der aufsicht
der amerikanischen vergrößert oder deren
bargeld anforderungen unterliegt dadurch
sind weder eine einlagen garantie noch
viele ähnliche auflagen erforderlich
sprechen also von einem freieren und
dadurch billigeren markt auf diese weise
wurde der eurobond markt zu einer der
säulen des globalen finanzsystems und ja
london wurde zum wichtigsten eurobonds
zentrum der welt wenn du eine
finanzierung in dollar braucht ist es
dadurch vielleicht sogar einfacher sie
auf den britischen markt zu bekommen als
in den vereinigten staaten selbst
der zweite bus hatte mit der ein
kolonialisierung zu tun der untergang
des britischen weltreichs hinterließ
viele kleine territorien die über die
ganze welt verstreut waren die bietet in
einigen fällen trotz ihrer neu
gewonnenen autonomie ihre politischen
und wirtschaftlichen beziehungen als
mutterland beibehielten wir sprechen
hier von kleinen orten wie den cayman
inseln bermuda und den jungen fernsehen
sind orte die sich daraufhin zu
wichtigen offshore finanzzentren
entwickelt haben um als steueroasen
ordentlich abzustauben oder diese
steueroasen bieten nicht nur extrem
niedrige steuersätze sondern garantieren
auch rechtssicherheit und anonymität und
dank ihrer verbindungen mit london wird
einen großteil ihrer aktivitäten über
die city abgewickelt und verwaltet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und schließlich kam der dritte schon
während der ära als die devisen
kontrolle oder ein großer teil der
damaligen finanzvorschriften abgeschafft
wurden diese politik war ein echter
turbo für die cd die seitdem immer
weiter und immer schneller gewachsen ist
doch mit dem exit wurde ein sturm
entfesselt wodurch diese
erfolgsgeschichte der city an einem
kritischen wendepunkt kam als die
britischen bürger am 23 juni 2016 für
den austritt aus der europäischen union
stimmten wurde die grundfesten der stg
erschüttert nachdem aixtron waren die
düsteren prognosen über die zukunft der
finanzindustrie großbritanniens
überwältigen das ende londons als
führendes internationales finanzzentrum
fast eine vollendete tatsache zu sein
aber natürlich treten prophezeiungen
nicht immer so ein die gedacht und
manchmal auch ganz anders also bis die
ohren jetzt wird spannend die
prophezeiung der apokalypse
londons rolle als finanz hauptstadt
europas schienen sich die ende
zuzuneigen es schien als würden die
banken und finanzinstitute in deckung
gehen und einen großteil ihrer geschäfte
auf dem kontinent in die europäischen
union sogar madrid hat seine eigene
plattform eingerichtet um sich einen
anteil an der beute zu schnappen wohl
tatsächlich war die erste direkte folge
des praxis dass amsterdam london als
wichtigstes handelszentrum in europa
überholt hat und natürlich ließen die
großen schlagzeilen nicht lange auf sich
warten
amsterdam überholt london als europas
führenden aktienmarkt wenig city der
finanzdistrikt von london hat seine
historische position als wichtigste eine
klare für den europäischen markt
verloren über nacht am ersten januar
2021 2 6 milliarden euro an täglichen
handelsumsätzen von london nach
amsterdam um den brüssler vorschriften
zu entsprechen
[Musik]
euronext der größte börsenbetreiber in
der europäischen union hat mit dem umzug
seiner rechenzentren von essex nach
bergamo in italien begonnen es sah so
aus als wären diese die ersten anzeichen
dafür dass london ein sinkendes schiff
ist nach schätzungen von schumpeter eine
führenden vermögensverwalter könnte das
politische risiko dass sich aus dem
wechsel gibt die in london notierten
unternehmen mit einem abschlag von 40%
gegenüber ihren internationalen
konkurrenten bestrafen 40 prozent doch
bevor wir ein urteil fällen sollten wir
uns einen moment zeit nehmen denn trotz
aller prognosen sieht die lage heute
schon viel weniger dramatisch aus
[Musik]
die bemühungen der europäischen union
ihre abhängigkeit vom vereinigten
königreich zu verringern scheinen sich
im moment nicht auszuzahlen london ist
nach wie vor der wichtigste ort um
kapital auch vom alten kontinent zu
beschaffen und das dominierende zentrum
für den devisen versicherungs und
schulden handelt und es sieht nicht so
aus als würde sich da hat etwas ändern
zumindest nicht in nächster zeit
und jetzt haltet euch fest tatsächlich
feierte die londoner finanz branche 2021
das erste jahr seit 2007 die umsätze
sind stark gewachsen die gehälter in der
branche sind fast 20 prozent gestiegen
und neuen schätzungen zufolge werden nur
7400 arbeitsplätze auf dem kontinent
verlagert das sind weniger als ein
prozent aller arbeitsplätze in der
finanzindustrie der britischen
hauptstadt für die schnelllebige und
dynamischen city ist das also nicht mehr
als ein augenblinzeln
[Musik]
aber die so lagen die schwarzmaler so
weiter nehmen nur wir müssen bedenken
dass unabhängig von der eu regierung 70
trotzdem der geschäfte in der city nicht
vor der europäischen union abhängen und
für all diese geschäfte konnte die
britische regierung nach ihrer
gewonnenen oder fähigkeit von brüssel
gar noch bessere rahmenbedingungen und
damit wachstums voraussetzungen schaffen
und durch diesen vierten buch scheint
der riesiges finanzdienstleistungs
cluster der in london entstanden ist
heute mit ausnahme new yorks wirklich
alle seine konkurrenten abgehängt zu
haben aber das meine liebe zuschauer ist
erst der anfang jetzt wo sie nicht mehr
an die europäische vorschriften gebunden
sind scheinen die kreativen britischen
behörden an vielen weiteren neuen plänen
zur verbesserung ihrer
wettbewerbsposition zu arbeiten ein
beispiel sind die so genannten dark
pools private systeme die den kauf und
verkauf große aktienpakete außerhalb der
öffentlichen börsen ermöglicht die eu
hat versucht diese strategie zu
unterbinden aber london scheint sich
viel flexibler zu gestalten natürlich
steht vor großen herausforderungen vor
allem wenn es um die aktienmärkte geht
so ist zum beispiel die zahl der
internationalen unternehmen die in
london notierten seit 2010 von 599 auf
370 gesunken infolgedessen ist die zahl
der in london notierten unternehmen von
mehr als zehn prozent der weltweiten
marktkapitalisierung auf knapp über drei
prozent gesunken aber auch die profile
der finanz branche scheint diese eher
nominalen zahlen keinen großen einfluss
zu haben
und somit ist eines klar geworden die
prophezeiung der bedenkenträger sind
makulatur der praxis ist ein äußerst
komplexes und vielschichtiges thema mit
einem breiten spektrum unterschiedlicher
auswirkungen aber zumindest in diesem
bereich kann man feststellen dass in den
dritten eher vorteile denn nachteile
gebracht hat die frage dabei ist
natürlich wirklich allen dritten oder
nur der londoner elite die sich um die
hypo elite in der city konzentriert gut
aber dieses thema werden der in einem
weiteren video auseinandernehmen
vergisst also bitte nicht das abo mit
glücklichem keines unserer videos zu
verpassen jetzt würde mich aber noch
eure meinung interessieren wie hast du
die folgen des tracks sind auf die
finanz branche eingeschätzt bist du von
der jetzigen entwicklung überrascht wie
sollte die eu auch diese britische
erfolgsgeschichte reagieren sollte sie
london unter druck setzen oder eher
konstruktiv daran arbeiten selbst agiler
und wettbewerbsfähiger zu werden welche
dinge fallen die hierzu einen die wir in
einem künftigen video gesprächen könnten
wie immer sind auf eure beiträge und
diskussion zu diesem thema schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe also dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat natürlich auch etwas
gelernt hat als jahr gibt es dort einen
leitpfosten freunde und natürlich freuen
uns auf jeder zeit und eine spende von
euch mit james hält dieses projekt und
weiterzuführen den paypal link dazu
findet ihre beschreibungen im video
machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]